- 1.6 million.
That's the number of people killed
by fungal infections
worldwide in a single year.
In 2021, at least 7,000 of
those deaths were in the U.S.
That's more than 15
times as many as in 1969.
We're not speeding towards
"The Last of Us" fungal apocalypse,
but health experts are worried
about the growing number
of severe fungal infections,
the kind that infect
the blood and attack
the lungs and the brain.
Let's go over three main reasons why fungi
are becoming more of a threat
and why it could get even worse.
Climate change may be having
an impact on fungal evolution.
This map from 2017 shows the
states that reported cases
of candida auris, an often deadly fungus.
Fast forward a few years,
not only has candida auris spread
beyond a handful of states,
but as you can see, the case
count has also skyrocketed.
The spread to more
places is also happening
with other severe fungal infections,
like histoplasmosis and valley fever.
- Their range has really exploded
over the last 50 years or so.
- Fungi, whether it's
ones you eat like these,
or the ones that make you sick
when their breather spores in,
they like temperatures that
are warm but not too hot.
So as the planet warms, places
that were too cold before
are becoming more fungi-friendly.
They may also be adapting to
be more tolerant of high heat,
and that includes the human body.
- Possibly because they've
adapted to warmer temperatures.
It seems like they've become
better at infecting us.
- Some recent evidence for
that comes from this study
that Dominique told me about.
In a lab, scientists grew
hundreds of generations
of a fungus called
cryptococcus deneoformans.
Some were grown at 98.6
degrees Fahrenheit.
Others at 86 degrees.
- It seemed that heat
and hotter temperatures
was really triggering them to mutate more.
- The fungi were adapting.
Scientists have been documented
this kind of heat-driven
evolution in the wild yet,
but that may be because this area
of research is just so new.
For most of human existence,
we've coexisted peacefully with fungi.
- It seems like they
might help us digest food,
maybe even fight disease.
Fungi are all around us.
They help connect our forests.
They break down our dead things.
Like they're just so critical to life.
- It's only recently that they've become
more worrisome pathogens.
Ironically, one reason for
this shift is modern medicine.
Better treatments for a range of diseases
has made it possible for
people to live longer,
even when their immune systems
aren't working optimally.
Infectious fungi are
particularly dangerous
for people with
compromised immune systems,
like patients who are going
through cancer treatment,
have advanced HIV infections,
or are taking high doses of steroids.
By some estimates, almost
3% of the U.S. population
is immunocompromised.
And this population is expected to grow.
Adding to the problem is that
we don't have a lot of options
for treating severe fungal infections.
It's hard to develop
treatments that kill fungi
without also being toxic to
humans, even at low doses.
That's because fungal cells
are similar to human ones.
- The fungi that are
currently causing disease
have developed resistance
to a lot of these known antifungals.
- This new study showed
there were three times
as many resistant candida
auris infections in 2021
as in each of the previous two years.
The pipeline for new drugs is also limited
because of a lack of investment,
but that's starting to change.
- So I think there has been more interest
from pharmaceutical
companies, from researchers
to really look at this as
a potential area of R&D,
but it's still kind of burgeoning.
- And there are drugs and clinical trials
from several companies.
It's important to
remember that even though
the threat from fungi is growing,
dying from a fungal infection
is still pretty rare.
This study estimated that in 2019,
7.7 million people died globally
from infections caused by bacteria
like e.coli and staph aureus.
That's almost five times as many
as have died because of a fungus.
And on a lighter note,
if you're still scared
that a fungus that looks like this
can turn you and your
friends into zombies-
- There's no indication
that that's gonna happen.
At least not any time in
the next few million years.
Fungi have to really evolve
to be able to do that.
- Whew, that's a relief.